landlords let tenants live in dangerous
or hazardous conditions yeah they do and
it's wrong I can agree with that yeah
yeah there are some really bad landlords
I tell you who's worst who's the the
worst landlord is there the council look
at um gemfield Tower yeah and all the
disgusting horrible things that have
happened the council houses are the
worst so when people say we should just
rely on the government to provide all
that housing it's like whoa mm come to
me man come to me I'll give you better
houses believe me and you'll pay me and
it's cool but I'll build houses don't go
to the government government terrible